these little fun packs they get for 4.99  for a lot of people watching it's not  for lost because this is where you learn  for five bucks this is worth learning  look at this little turtle  oh this one this is what I was hoping  for Pokemon [ __ ] oh [ __ ] I think  I got a 1990  . you guys know which Pokemon is this  you feel good about these  oh there's a third one all right now  watch this I can tweet this and be like  be like is it up what's up this one's  550. how much was the bag four bucks  ten dollars what are you paying  attention wow you start building up your  knowledge base why'd I buy this bag you  so many bags there were that wasn't  [ __ ] luck that's the [ __ ] reps  that's the hours I put in the last 25  years on pop culture flipping this is  [ __ ] work and creativity now you're  learning marketing you're learning  copywriting  take all this social media selling stuff  it all builds I really think thrifting  on a Saturday is a two three hundred  dollar Saturday